oh my god oh my god  the huge cruise ship bled its horn but  it was too late for the much smaller  tourist vessel to get out of the way the  13 dec opera with some two and a half  thousand passengers on board hit the  river countess and then pushed past it  crashing into the dock deafening noise  coming closer it was the sound of the  horn we were lucky because it could have  been much worse  I thought the ship would reach my house  the ambulance got here after 25 or 30  minutes but didn't do anything they  stopped to watch what was happening a  bit like everyone else did medical  authorities say four people were injured  soon after the collision protesters  gathered to renew their call to ban  large cruise ships from the port of  Venice the safety of big ships in the  busy waters of European cities has  become an urgent issue after last week's  Danube River accident when a collision  between a cruise liner and a tourist  boat left seven people dead and 21  missing  you